story that you tell yourself has a
massive impact on how you feel if you
feel like
is a dirty bad action that you shouldn't
do that you should feel ashamed about
Downstream from that you're going to
feel ashamed if you're hiding on youth
from your partner that is a huge huge
red flag personally partner is another
concern but for you it's a big deal
because you're going to feel that sort
of disgust self-hatred shame guilt thing
come through but I do think that if you
want to increase the strive in your
relationship just saying okay if we want
to do anything will we do it together
try and tell me that that's not going to
increase thrive in a relationship almost
all of this that happens happens in
relationships if you took a pie chart of
almost all of it is in relationships
very very small amount of is in casual
relationships